the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
some of the things we've seen during
linear regression some of the things
we've seen in terms of the basic
modeling that we've had before we're not
going to go back to much inference
questions it's really going to be about
modeling and in a way generalized linear
models as the word says are just a
generalization of linear models and
they're actually extremely useful there
so often forgotten about and people just
jump onto machine learning and
sophisticated techniques but those
things do the job the job quite well so
let's see in what sense they were
generalization of the linear models all
right so remember the linear model
looked like this we said that Y was
equal to X transpose beta plus Epsilon
right that was a linear regression model
and it's another way to say this is that
if I and it let's assume that those were
say Gaussian with mean 0 and identity
covariance matrix then another way to
say this is that the conditional
distribution of Y given X is equal to
sorry is a Gaussian with mean x
transpose beta and variance well we had
a Sigma square which I will forget as
usual X transpose beta and then Sigma
squared ok so here we just assumed that
so what is regression is just saying I'm
trying to explain why as a function of X
given X I'm assuming a distribution for
the Y and this X is just going to be
here to help me model what the what the
mean of this Gaussian is right I mean I
could have something crazy I could have
something that looks like Y given X is n
0 X transpose beta and then this guy
could be some other thing which looks
like I don't know some X transpose gamma
squared times I don't know xx transpose
plus identity some crazy thing that
depends on X here right and we
deliberately assumed that all the thing
that depends on X shows up in the mean
ok and so what I have here is that Y
given X is a Gaussian with a mean that
depends on X and covariance matrix Sigma
square identity now the linear model
assumed a very specific form for the
mean it said I want the mean to be equal
to X transpose beta which remember was
the sum from say J equals 1 to P of beta
J XJ right where the X J's are the
coordinates of X but I could do
something also more complicated right
that could have something that looks
like instead replace this by I don't
know sum of beta J log of X to the J
divided by X to the J squared or
something like this right I could do
this as well
so there's two things that we've assumed
the first one is that when I look at the
conditional distribution of Y even X X
affects only the mean I also assume that
it was Gaussian and that it affects only
the mean and the mean is affected in a
very specific way which is linear in X
all right so this is essentially the
things we're gonna try to relax so the
first thing that we assume the fact that
Y was Gaussian and had only its mean the
dependent on X is what's called the
random component it just says that the
response variables you know sort of
makes sense to assume that they're
Gaussian and and everything was
essentially captured right so there's
this property of gaussians that if you
tell me the if the variance is known all
you need to tell me to understand
exactly what
the distribution of a Gaussian is all
you need to tell me is its expected
value all right so that this mu of X and
the second thing is that we had this
link that says well I need to find a way
to use my X's to explain this view and
the link was exactly Mew of X was equal
to X transpose beta okay now we are
talking about generalized linear models
so this part here where Mew of X is of
the form the way I want my beta my X to
show up is linear this will never be
questioned in principle I could head out
of third point which is just question
this part the fact that mu of X is X
transpose beta I could have some more
complicated nonlinear a function of X
and then we'll never do that because
we're talking about generalized linear
model the only thing with generalize are
the random component the conditional
distribution of Y given X and the link
that just says well once you actually
tell me that the only thing I need to
figure out is the mean I'm just gonna
slap it exactly this X transpose beta
thing without any transformation of X
transpose beta okay so those are the two
things it will become clearer what I
mean this sounds like a tautology but
let's just see how we could extend that
so what we're gonna do
I'm generalized linear models right so
when they talk about GL ends the first
thing I'm gonna do with my X is turning
into some X transpose beta and that's
just the L part right this I'm not gonna
be able to change that's the way it
works I'm not gonna do anything on
linear but the two things I'm gonna
change is this random component which is
that Y which used to be some Gaussian
with mean mu of X here in Sigma squared
so Y given X sorry this is going to
become Y given X follows some
distribution
and I'm not going to allow any
distribution I want something that looks
comes from the exponential family who
knows what the exponential family of
distribution is this is not the same
thing as the exponential distribution
it's a family of distributions all right
so we'll see that Wow
what can that be
oh yeah that's actually me so I'm sorry
okay I'm in presentation mode okay so so
essentially this is going to be a family
of distributions and what makes them
exponential typically is that there's an
exponential that shows up in the
definition of the density all right
we'll see that the Gaussian belongs to
the exponential family but they're
slightly less expected ones because
there's this crazy thing that a to the X
is exponential X log a which makes the
exponential show up without being there
so if there's an exponential or some
power it's gonna show up but it's more
than that so we'll actually come to this
particular family of distribution why
this particular family because in a way
everything we've done for the linear
model with Gaussian is gonna extend
fairly naturally to this family all
right and it actually also because it
encompasses pretty much everything all
the distributions we've discussed before
all right so the two the second thing
that I want to question right so before
we just said well mu of X was directly
equal to this thing nu of X was directly
x transpose beta so I knew I was gonna
have an X transpose beta and I said well
I could do something with this X
transpose beta before I used it to
explain the expected value but I'm
actually taking it like that here we're
gonna say let's extend this to some
function
is equal to this thing now admittedly
this is not the most natural way to
think about it which you would probably
feel more comfortable doing is right
something like mu of X is a function
let's call it f of X transpose beta but
here I just decide to call F G inverse
okay that's just my chambers yes yeah I
mean what transformation you want to put
on your axes no certainly not right I
mean if I give you if I force you to
work with x1 plus x2 you cannot work
with any function of x1 plus any
function of X - right so all right so
yeah the transformation would be just
the simple part of your linear
regression problem where you would take
your X's with transform them and then
just apply another linear regression
this is genuinely new any other question
all right
so this function G and the reason why I
sort of have to like stick to this
slightly less natural way of defining it
is because that's G that gets a name not
G inverse that gets the name and the
name of G is the link function so if I
want to give you a generalized linear
models I give you I need to give you two
ingredients the first one is the random
component which is the distribution of Y
given X and it's good it can be anything
in the what will the X what's called the
exponential family of distributions so
for example I could say Y given X is
Gaussian with mean mu X Sigma square
identity but I could also tell you why
given ax is gamma with shape parameter
equal to alpha of X okay I could do some
weird things like this and the second
thing is I need to give you a link from
and the link function is gonna become
very clear how you pick a link function
and the only reason that you actually
pick a link function is because of
compatibility this mu of X I call it mu
because mu of X is always the
conditional expectation of Y given X
always which means that let's think of Y
as being a Bernoulli random variable
which where does mu of X live 0 1 right
that's the expectation of a bernal it's
just the probability that my coin flip
gives me 1 so it's a number between 0
and 1 but this guy right here if my X's
are anything right think of any body
measurements plus I take linear
combinations with arbitrarily large
coefficients this thing can be any real
number so the link function what it's
effectively gonna do is make those two
things compatible it's gonna take my
number which for example is constraint
to be between 0 & 1 and map it into the
entire real line if I have mu which is
forced to be positive for example in an
exponential distribution the mean is
positive right
that's the say I don't know inter
arrival time for question process this
thing is known to be positive for an
exponential I need to map something
that's exponential to the entire real
line
I need a function that takes something
positive in tickets everywhere so we'll
see by the end of this chapter you will
have a hundred ways of doing this but
there are some more traditional ones
than another so before we go any further
I gave you this example of I gave you
this example of a Bernoulli random
variable let's see a few examples that
actually fit there yes
well actually this will not come up
later it should be very clear from here
because if I actually have a model I
just want it to be plausible right I
mean what happens if I certainly decide
that my so this is what's gonna happen
you're gonna have only data to fit this
model let's say you actually forget
about the this thing here you can always
do this right you can always say I'm
gonna pretend my wise or any just happen
to be the realizations of say gaussians
that happen to be 0 or 1 only you can
always like stuff that in some linear
model right you will have so many
squares estimator for beta but what's
gonna happen and it's gonna be fine for
all the points that you see it will
definitely put some number that's
actually between 0 and 1 right so this
is what your picture is gonna look like
you're gonna have a bunch of values for
X this is your Y and for different so
these are the values of x that you will
get and for Y you will see either 0 or 1
right right that's what you're that's
what you're a bernly data set would look
like with a 1 dimensional X now if you
do least squares on this you will find
this and for this guy this line
certainly takes values between 0 & 1 but
let's say now you get an X here you're
gonna actually start pretending that the
probability it spits out one
conditionally an X is like 1.2 and
that's gonna be weird okay
any other question all right so let's
start with some examples right
throughout this course so the first one
is uh so oldest things are taken so
there's a few books on journalizing your
models generalize add it to models and
there's tons of applications that you
can see those are extremely versatile
and as soon as you want to do modeling
to explain some Y given X you sort of
need to do that if you want to go beyond
linear models so this was the disease
occurring rate so you have a disease
epidemic and
you want to basically model the expected
number of new cases given at a certain
time okay so you have time that
progresses for each of your reservation
each of your relation is a timestamp say
I don't know 20th day and your response
is the number of new cases and you're
gonna actually put your model directly
on new right when I looked at this
everything here was on Mew itself on the
expected right knew of X is always the
expected the conditional expectation of
Y given X right so all I need to model
is this expected value so this mu I'm
gonna actually say so I look at some
parameters and it says well it often it
increases exponentially so I want to say
I have some sort of exponential trend I
can parameterize that in several ways
and the two parameters I want to slap in
is like some sort of gamma which is just
a coefficient and then there's some rate
Delta that's in the exponential okay so
if I tell you it's exponential that's a
nice family of functions you might want
to think about okay so here mu of X if I
want to keep the notation X is gamma
exponential Delta X right except that
here my X are T 1 T 2 T 3 etc ok and I
want to find what the parameter is gamma
and Delta R because I want to be able to
maybe compare different epidemics and
see if they have the same parameter or
maybe just do some prediction based on
the data that I have without to
extrapolate in the future okay so here
clearly mu of X is not of the form x
transpose beta right that's not X
transpose beta at all and it's actually
not even a function of X transpose beta
right there's two parameters gamma and
Delta and it's not of the form so here I
have X which is 1 and X right I have to
probe so what I do here is that I say
well first let me transform you in such
a way that I can hope to see something
this linear so if I transform you I'm
gonna have the log of mu which is log of
this thing right so log of mu of X is
equal to log of gamma plus log of
exponential Delta X which is Delta X
okay and now this thing is actually
linear in X so I have that this guy is
my first beta one and so that's beta 1
times 1 and this guy is beta 2 times
sorry that's a bit at 0 times 1 and this
guy is beta 1 times X ok so that looks
like a linear model I just have to
change my parameters my parameters beta
1 becomes the log of gamma and beta 2
becomes Delta itself and the reason why
we do this is because well the way we
put those gamma and those Delta was just
so that we have some parametrization it
just so happens that if we want this to
be linear we need to just change the
parameterization itself this is gonna
have some effects we know that it's
gonna have some effect in the Fisher
information is gonna have a bunch of
effect to change those things but that's
what we need needs to be done to have a
generalized linear model now here the
function that I took to turn it into
something that's linear is simple it
came directly from some natural thing I
would do here which is taking the log
and so the function G the link that I
take is called the log link very
creatively and it's just the function
that I apply to new so that I see
something that's linear and that looks
like this ok so now this only tells me
how to deal with the link function but I
still have to deal with point 1 and this
again is just some modeling given some
data some random data
what distribution do you choose to
explain the randomness and this I mean
unless there's no choice you know it's
just a matter of practice right I mean
why would it be Gaussian and not you
know doubly exponential this is you know
there's matters of convenience that come
into this and there's just matter of
experience that come into this all right
when you
with engineers they have a very good
notion of what the distribution should
be at they have you know Weibull
distribution you know it's their due
optics and things like this so there's
some distribution has just come up but
sometimes you just have to work now here
what do we have the thing we're trying
to measure why as we said so mu is the
expectation the conditional expectation
of Y given X but Y is the number of new
cases right well it's a number of and
the first thing you should think of when
you think about number of if it were
bounded above you would think binomial
baby but here it's just a number so you
think question
that's how insurers think I have a
number of you know claims per year this
is a personal distribution okay and
hopefully they can model it the
conditional distribution of the number
of claims given everything that they
actually ask you in this surveys that I
hear you now fill in 15 minutes all
right so so now you have this Poisson
distribution and that's just a modeling
assumption there's no particular reason
why you should do this except that you
know that might be a good idea and the
expected value of your question has to
be this mu I okay at time I any question
about this slide okay so let's switch to
another example
another example is the so called pre
capture rate so here what you're
trumping when you're interested in is
the rate capture of preys yi4 given prey
and you have X I which is your
explanation and this is just the density
of prey so you're trying to explain the
rate of captures of phrase given the
density of the prey okay and so you need
to find some sort of relationship
between the two and here again you talk
to experts and what they tell you is
that well it's going to be increasing
rate I mean animals like predators are
gonna you know just eat more if there's
more praise and but at some point
they're just gonna level off because
they're just gonna be completely full
and they're gonna stop stop capturing
those praising you're just gonna have
some some phenomenon that look
like this so here's a curve that sort of
makes sense right as your capture rate
goes from zero through one you're
increasing and then you see you have
this like concave function that says
that you know at some point it levels
off okay so here one way I could I mean
there's again many ways I could just
model a function that looks like this
but a simple one that has only two
parameters is this one where mu I is
just this function of X I where I have
some parameter alpha here in some
parameter H here okay
so there's clearly so this function
there's one that essentially tells you
so this thing starts at zero for sure
and essentially alpha tells you how
sharp this thing is and H tells you at
which point you end here okay but it's
not exactly what those values are equal
to but it tells you this okay so so you
know simple and well no okay sorry
that's actually alpha which is the
maximum capture no rate and H represents
the pre density I wish the capture rate
is so that's the half time
okay so there's actual value since
alright so now I have this function it's
certainly not a function
there's no I don't see it as a function
of X so I need to find something that
looks like a function of X okay so now
here there's no log there's no well I
could actually take a log here but I
would have log of X and log of X plus h
so that would be weird so what we
proposed to do here is to look rather
than looking at new I we look at 1 over
mu I right and so since your function
was new I
when you take one over m UI you get h
plus X I divided by Alpha X I which is H
over alpha times 1 over X I plus 1 over
alpha and now if I'm willing to make
this transformation of variables and say
actually I don't
my X whether it's the density of prey or
the inverse density of prey it really
doesn't matter I can always make the
transformation when the data comes then
I'm actually just going to think of this
as being some linear function beta 0
plus beta 1 which is this guy times 1
over X I and now my new variable becomes
1 over X I and now it's linear and the
transformation I had to take was this 1
over X which is called the reciprocal
link okay you can probably guess what
the exponential link is gonna be and
things like this alright so we'll talk
about other links that have slightly
less obvious names now again
modeling right so this was the random
component this was the easy part now I
need to just you know pour in some dummy
knowledge about how do I think this
function this Y which is which is the
rate of capture of praise I want to
understand how this thing is actually
changing what is the randomness of this
thing around its mean and you know
something that's so that comes from this
textbook the standard deviation of
capture rate might be approximately
proportional to the mean rate so you
need to find a distribution that
actually has this property it turns out
that this happens for gamma
distributions all right in gamma
distributions just like say for Poisson
distribution the well for Poisson the
variance and mean are of the same order
here is the Steyr deviation that's of
the same order as the as the as the mean
okay forget mass and it's a positive
distribution as well alright so here's a
now since we're sort of constrained to
work under the exponential family of
distributions then you can just go
through your list and just you know
decide which one works best for you
right all right third example so here we
have binary response here essentially
the binary response variable indicates
the presence or absence of post
operative deforming for ketosis on
children and here rather than having one
covariant which was before in the first
example was time and the second example
with the density here there's three
covariance that you measure on children
the first one is age of the child and
the second one is the number of
vertebrae involved in the operation and
the third one is the start of the range
right so where it is on the on the spine
okay so so the response variable here is
you know did it work or not right I mean
that's very simple and so here it's nice
because the random component is these
just one as I said any random variable
that takes only two outcomes must be a
bernly right so there's that's nice
there's no modeling going on here so you
know that Y given X is going to be
bernly but of course all your efforts
are gonna try to understand what the
conditional mean of your bernal what the
conditional probability of being one is
gonna be okay and so in particular so
I'm just here I'm spelling it out before
we close those examples I cannot say
that new of X is X transpose beta for
exactly this picture that I drove for
you here right there's just no way here
the goal of doing this is certainly to
be able to extrapolate for yet unseen
children whether this is something that
we should be doing and maybe the range
of X's is actually going to be slightly
out and so okay I I don't want to say
that I have a negative probability of
outcome or positive one so sorry I worry
or a one that's lower than one so I need
to make this transformation so what I
need to do is to transform mu which is
we know only a number all we know is a
number between 0 and 1 and we need to
transform it in such a way that it Maps
the entire real line or you know
reciprocal e to say that
or inversely I should say that f of X
transpose B there should be a number
between 0 and 1 okay I need to find a
function that takes any real number and
maps that into 0 & 1 and we'll see that
again but you you have an army of
functions that do that for you what are
those functions I'm sorry traight oh
yeah I want them to be invertible right
I have an army a function I'm not asking
for one soldier in this army I want the
name of this army well they're not
really invertible either a so they're
actually in stats textbooks because
remember statisticians don't know how to
integrate functions but they know how to
turn a function into a Gaussian integral
so we know it integrates to 1 & 6 like
this same thing here we don't know how
to build functions that you know are
invertible and map the entire real line
to 0 1 but there's all the cumulative
distribution functions that do that for
us so I can use any of those guys and
that's what I'm gonna be doing actually
all right so just to recap what I just
said as we were speaking so a normal
linear model is not appropriate for
those examples if only because the if
only because the response variable is
not necessarily Gaussian so and also
because the linear model has to be the
mean has to be transformed before I can
actually apply a linear model we're all
this plausible nonlinear models that I
actually came up with okay so so the
family we're gonna go for is the
exponential family of distributions and
we're gonna be able to show so one of
the nice part of this is to actually
compute maximum likelihood estimators
for those right in the linear model
maximum like in the Gaussian linear
model maximum likelihood was as nice
that it gets right this actually was the
least squares estimator we had a closed
form
X transpose X inverse X transpose Y and
that was it okay we had to just take one
derivative here we're gonna have a
generally concave likelihood we're not
gonna be able to actually solve this
thing directly in closed form unless
it's Gaussian but we will have I will
see actually how this is not just a
black box optimization of a concave
function we have a lot of properties of
this concave function and we will be
able to show some iterative algorithms
will basically see how when you hope
open the box of of convex optimization
you will actually be able to see how
things work and actually implement it
using least squares so each iteration of
this iterative algorithm will
essentially be le square so that's
actually quite cute it's also very
demonstrative of statisticians being you
know pretty ingenious so that they don't
have to call in some statistical
software but just can repeatedly call
their least squares Oracle within a
statistical something okay so what is
the exponential family right I promise
to you the exponential family before we
go into this let me just tell you
something about exponential families and
what's what's the only thing that
differentiate an exponential family from
all possible distribution an exponential
family has two parameters right and
those are not really parameters but
there's the theta parameter of my
distribution okay so it's gonna be
indexed by some parameter here I'm only
talking about the distribution of say
some random variable or some random
vector okay so here in this slide you
see that the parameter theta that index
those family that index to the
distribution is K dimensional and the
space of the X's that I'm looking at so
that should really be Y right so that
what I'm gonna plug in here is the
conditional distribution of Y given X
and theta is going to depend on X but
this really is the Y that's there this
distribution of the response variable
and so this is on two right so I have
I'm gonna assume that Y takes Q
dimensional is Q dimensional clearly
soon Q is gonna be equal to one but I
can define those things generally okay
so I have this I have to tell you what
this looks like and let's assume that
this is a probability density function
so
right this notation the fact that I just
put my theta in subscript it's just for
me to remember that this is the variable
that indicates the random variable and
this is just the parameter but I could
just write it as a function of theta and
X right this is gonna be right if you
were in calc in multivariable out you
would have two parameters theta and X
and you would need to give me a function
now think of all think of X and theta as
being one-dimensional at this point
think of all the functions that can be
depending on theta and X there's many of
them and in particular there's many ways
theta and X can interact what the
exponential family does for you is that
it restricts the way these things can
actually interact with each other it's
essentially saying the following it's
saying this is gonna be of the form
exponential so this exponential is
really not much because I could put a
log next to it but what I want is that
this the way theta and X interact has to
be of the form theta times X in an
exponential okay so that's the simplest
that's one of the ways you can think of
them interacting you just take the
product of the two
now clearly this is not a very rich
family so what I'm allowing myself is to
just slap on some terms that depend only
on theta and depend only on X okay so
let's just call this thing I don't know
f of X G of theta okay so here I've
restricted the way theater and X can
interact so I have something that
depends only on X and theta depends only
on theta and here I have this very
specific interaction and that's all that
exponential families are doing for you
okay so if we go back to this slide this
is much more general right if I want to
go from theta and X in R to theta and X
theta in R to theta in RK and X in R
cube I cannot take the product of theta
and X I cannot even take the inner
product between theta and X because
they're not even of compatible
dimensions but what I can do is to first
map my theta into something
and map my eggs into something so that I
actually end up having the same
dimensions and then I can take the inner
product that's the natural
generalization of this simple product
okay so what I have is right so if I
want to go from theta to X what I'm
gonna first do is I'm gonna so I'm gonna
take theta
eta of theta so let's say ETA 1 of theta
2 ETA K of theta and then I'm gonna
actually take X becomes G 1 of X all the
way to G K of X and what I'm gonna do is
take the inner product so it's called
this ETA and let's call this T and I'm
gonna take the inner product of Vita and
T right which is just the sum from J / 1
to K of ETA J of theta times T 1 TJ of K
of X ok so it's just a way to say I want
the simple interaction but in higher
dimension the simplest way I can
actually make those things happen is
just by taking inner product okay and so
now what it's telling is that the
distribution so I want the exponential
time something that depends only on
theta and something that depends only on
X and so what it tells me is that what
I'm gonna take P of theta X is just
gonna be something which is exponential
times the sum from J equal 1 to K of ETA
J theta T G of X and then I'm gonna have
a function that depends only so let me
write it for now like C of theta and
then a function that depends only on X
let me call it H of X and for
convenience there's no particular reason
why I do that I'm taking this function C
of theta and I'm just actually pushing
it in there so I can write C of theta as
exponential
- a log of one over C of theta right and
now I have exponential times exponential
so I push it in and this thing actually
looks like exponential sum from J equal
1 to K of ETA J theta G G of X minus log
1 over C of theta times H of X and this
thing here log 1 over C of theta I call
actually B of theta because C I called
it C but I can actually directly call it
this guy B and I don't actually care
about C itself now why do not why don't
I put back also X H of X in there
because H of X is really here - just how
to put it okay H of X and and and B of
theta don't play the same role B of
theta in many ways is the normalizing
constant right I want this density to
integrate to 1 if I did not have this
guy I'm not guaranteed that this thing
integrates to 1 but by tweaking this
function P of theta or cos theta they're
equivalent I can actually ensure that
this thing integrates - so VF theta is
just a normalizing constant H of X is
something that's going to be funny for
us it's gonna be something that allows
us to be able to treat both discrete and
continuous variables within the
framework of within the framework of
exponential families so for those that
are familiar with this this is
essentially saying that H of X is really
just a change of measure when I actually
look at the density of P of theta this
is with respect to some measure the fact
that I just multiplied by a function of
X just means that I'm not looking that
this guy here without H of theta is not
the density with respect to the original
measure but it's the density with
respect to the distribution that has H
as a density that's all I'm saying
so I can first transform my exes and
then take the density with respect to
that if you don't want to think about
densities or measures you don't have to
this is just the way this is just the
definition is there any question about
this definition all right so it looks
complicated but it's actually
essentially the simplest way you could
think about it you have you want to be
able to have X and theta interact and
you just say I want the interaction to
be of the form exponential x times theta
and if they're higher dimensions I'm
going to take the exponential of a
function of X in a product with a
function of theta all right so I claimed
since the beginning that the Gaussian
was such an example so let's just do it
so is the Gaussian of the is the
interaction between theta and X in a
Gaussian of the forming a product and
the answer is yes actually whether I
know or dot what the variance is okay so
let's start for the case where I
actually do not know what the variance
is so here I have X is n new Sigma
squared this is all one-dimensional and
here I'm gonna assume that my parameter
is both mu and Sigma squared
okay so what I need to do is to have
some function of MU some function of
Sigma square and ticket in your product
of some function of X and some other
function of X okay so I want to show
that so P theta of X is what well it's 1
over square roots Sigma 2 pi exponential
minus X minus mu squared over 2 Sigma
squared right so that's just my Gaussian
density and I want to really I want to
say that this thing here so clearly the
exponential shows up already I want to
show that this is something that looks
like you know ETA 1 of sorry so that was
yeah ETA 1 of say mu sigma squared so I
have only two of those guys so I'm going
to need only two ITA's right so I want
it to be ETA 1 of mu and Sigma times T 1
of X plus ETA 2
new one new Sigma squared times t2 of X
right so I want to have something like
that that shows up and the rest is gonna
and and the only things that are left I
want them to depend either only on theta
or only on X so to find that out we just
need to in to expand okay so I'm gonna
first put everything into my my
exponential and expand this guy so the
first term here is going to be minus x
squared over 2 Sigma square the second
term is going to be minus mu squared
over 2 Sigma squared and then the cross
term is going to be plus X mu divided by
Sigma squared and then I'm gonna put
this guy here so I have a minus log
Sigma root 2 pi ok ok is this so this
term here is a has contained an
interaction between X and the parameters
this term here contains a detraction
between X and the parameters so let me
try to write them in a way that I want
this guy only depends on the parameters
this guy only depends on the parameter
so I'm gonna rearrange things and so I'm
that this is of the form x squared well
let's say who's getting the minus ETA
okay so so it's x squared times minus 1
over 2 Sigma squared plus X times mu
over Sigma squared right so that's this
term here that's this term here now I
need to get this guy here and that's -
so I'm gonna write it like this - and
now I have nu squared over 2 Sigma
squared plus log Sigma square root 2 pi
ok
and now this thing is definitely of the
form T 1 of x times did I call them the
right way or not of course not
okay so that's going to be T 2 of X
times ETA 2 of X ETA 2 of theta this guy
is going to be T 1 of x times ETA 1 of
theta all right so just a function of
theta times a function of X just a
function of theta times a function of X
and the way I combined it is just by
summing them and this is gonna be my V
of theta what is H of X 1 there's one
thing I can actually play with and this
is something you're gonna have some free
choices right your this is not actually
completely determined here is that for
example right so when I write the log
Sigma square root 2 pi this is just log
of Sigma plus log square root 2 pi so I
have two choices here either my B
becomes this guy or so either I have B
of theta which is mu squared over 2
Sigma squared plus y Sigma square root 2
pi and H of X is equal to 1 or I have
that B of theta is nu squared over 2
Sigma squared plus log Sigma and H of X
is equal to what well I can just push
this guy out right I can push it out of
the exponential and so it's just square
root of 2 of 2 pi which is a function of
X technically I mean it's a constant
function of X but it's a function so you
can see that it's not like completely
clear how you're gonna do the trade off
right so the constant terms can go
either in B or in H but you know why
bother with you know tracking down being
H when you can actually stuff everything
into one and just call h1 and call it a
day
right so you can just forget about H you
know it's 1 and think about the rest H
won't matter actually for estimation
purposes or anything like this
alright so that's basically everything
that's written when Sigma square is
known what's happening is that this guy
here is no longer a function of theta
right agreed this is no longer a
parameter when Sigma square is known
then theta is equal to MU only there's
no Sigma square going on so this
everything that depends on Sigma square
can be thought as a constant think 1 so
in particular this term here does not
belong in the interaction between X and
theta it belongs to H right so if Sigma
is known then this guy is only a
function of H of X so H of X becomes
exponential x squared minus x squared
over 2 Sigma squared right that's just a
function of X
so if you complete this computation when
you're going to get is that your new
one-parameter thing is that P theta P
theta X is not equal to exponential X
times mu over Sigma squared - well it's
still the same thing and then you have
your H of X that comes out x squared
over 2 Sigma squared ok so that's my H
of X that's still my B of theta and
that's my this is my Chi 1 of X and this
is my ETA 1 of theta and remember theta
is just equal to new in this case okay
so if I ask you prove that this
distribution belong to an exponential
family you just have to you know work it
out typically it's expanding what's in
the exponential and see what's and just
write it in this term and identify all
the components right so here notice
those guys don't even get an index
anymore because there's just one of them
so I wrote theta 1 and T 1 but it's
really just a time T oh sorry this guy
also goes right this is also a constant
right so I can actually just put Sigma
divided by Sigma square root 2 pi so H
of X is what actually is the density of
it's not standard it's centered it has
mean 0 but it has variance Sigma square
right but it's the density of a Gaussian
and this is what I meant when I said H
of X is really just telling you with
respect to which distribution which
measure you're taking the density and so
this thing here is really telling you
the density of my Gaussian with mean mu
is equal to this with respect to a
centered Gaussian is this guy right
that's what it means if this thing ends
up being a density it just means that
now you just have a new measure which is
this density so it's just saying that
the density of the Gaussian with mean mu
with respect to the Gaussian with mean 0
is just this alright so let's move on so
here is that I said you could actually
do all these computations and forget
about the fact that X is continuous you
can actually do it with pmf's
and do it for X is discrete this
actually also tells you if you right if
you can actually get the same form for
your density which is of the form
exponential times the product of the
depth of the I'm at the interaction
between theta and X is just taking this
product and then a function only of
theta and the function only of X for the
PMF it also works ok so I claim that the
bernly belongs to this family all right
so the the PMF of a Bernoulli we say
parameter P is P to the X 1 minus P to
the 1 minus X right because we know so
that's only for X equals 0 or 1 and the
reason is because when X is equal to 0
this is 1 minus P 1 X is equal to 1 this
is P ok we've seen that when we were
looking at likelihoods for Bernoulli's
ok this is not clear this is gonna look
like this at all but let's do it
okay so what does this thing look like
well the first thing I want to do is to
make an exponential show up so what I'm
gonna write is I'm gonna write P to the
X as exponential ikz log P right and so
I'm gonna do that for the other one so
this thing here so I'm gonna get
exponential x log P plus 1 minus x log 1
minus P so what I need to do is to
collect my terms in X and my terms in
whatever parameters I have so here if
theta is equal to P so if I do this what
I end up having is equal to exponential
so the term in X is log P minus log 1
minus P so that's x times log P over 1
minus P and then the term that rest is
just this that stays is just 1 times log
1 minus P but I want to see this as a
minus something right it was minus P of
theta so I'm gonna write it as minus
well I can just keep the plus and I'm
gonna do and that's all ha ha well this
is of the form exponential something
that depends only on x times something
that depends only on theta minus a
function that depends only on theta and
then H of X is equal to 1 again ok so
let's see so I have t1 of X is equal to
X that this guy ETA 1 of theta is equal
to log P 1 minus P and B of theta is
equal to log 1 over 1 minus P okay and H
of X
is equal to 1 all right guys we want to
do personal or you want to have it in
homework it's a dilemma because that's
an easy homework versus no homework at
all but maybe something more difficult
ok who wants to do it now who does not
want to raise their hand now who wants
to raise their hand now all right so
[Music]
let's move on I'll just I'll just do it
do you want to do the gammas instead in
the homework that's gonna be fun
I'm not even I'm not even getting
proposed to do the gammas all right so
so this is the gamma distribution it's
brilliantly cause golf gamma because it
has the gamma function just like the
beta distribution was at the beta
function in there they look very similar
when is defined over our plus the
positive real line and the remember the
beta was defined over the interval 0 1
and it's of the form X to some power
times exponential minus X to some times
something
right so there's a function a polynomial
in X where the exponent depends on the
parameter and then there's a exponential
minus x times something depends on the
parameters so this is going to also look
like some function of X sorry like some
exponential distribution can somebody
guess what is going to be T 2 of X oh
those are the functions of X that show
up in this product right remember when
we have this we just need to take some
transformations of X so it looks linear
in those things and not in X itself
remember we had x squared and X for
example in the gaussian case if it's
still there yeah it's still there right
t2 was X square what do you think X is
gonna teach you of X here I so here's a
hint
t1 is gonna be X yeah Arjun what is
gonna be t2 yeah you cannot this one is
taken this one I stated what log X right
because this X to the a minus 1 I'm
going to write it as X plane
a minus 1 log X all right so basically a
table 1 is gonna be a minus 1 beta 2 is
gonna be minus 1 over B well actually
the opposite and then you're gonna have
but this is actually not too complicated
all right then those parameters get
names a the shape parameter B's the
scale parameter it doesn't really matter
you have other things that are called
the inverse gamma distribution which has
this form the difference is that the
parameter alpha shows negatively there
and then the inverse Gaussian
distribution
you know just densities you can come up
with and it just happened to fall and
this in this family and there's other
ones that you can actually put in there
that we've seen before the chi-square is
actually part of this family the beta
distribution is part of this family
binomial distribution is part of this
family
well that's easy cuz the Burling was the
negative binomial which is some stopping
time now the first time you hit number
so number of successes when you flip
some vernal equinox it at you can
actually write them as part of the
exponential family so the main goal of
this slide is to convince you that this
is actually a pretty broad range of
distributions because it basically
includes everything we've seen but not
anything they're not sorry it plus more
okay yeah
yeah like uniform anything that has the
support that depends on the parameter
he's not gonna fall it's not the
anything in there
right and you can actually convince
yourself why anything that has the
parameter the the support that does not
that depends on the parameter is not
gonna be part of this guy it's kind of a
hard thing to if I ask you prove that
it's not
and you wouldn't prove this kick this
rule it's kind of little difficult but
the way you can convince yourself is
that remember the only interaction
between X and theta that I allowed was
taking the product of those guys and
then the exponential right if you have
something that depends on some parameter
let's say you're gonna see something
that looks like this right for uniform
it looks like this well this is not of
the form exponential x times theta
there's an interaction between X and
theta here but it's actually certainly
not of the form X exponential like sine
theta so this is definitely not gonna be
part of the exponential family and every
time you start doing things like that
but it's just not gonna happen actually
to be fair I'm not even sure that all
this guy's when you allow them to have
all their parameters free are actually
gonna be part of this for example the
beta probably is but I'm not actually
entirely convinced there's books on
exponential families all right so let's
go back so here we've put a lot of
effort understanding how big how much
wider than the Gaussian distribution can
we think of for the response of our the
conditional distribution of our response
Y given X so let's go back to the
generalized linear models right so
dinner when we're all said okay the
random component Y has to be part of
some exponential family distribution
check we know what this means
so now I have to understand two things I
have to understand how what is the
expectation right because that's
actually what I model right I take
expectation the conditional expectation
of Y given X so I need to understand
given this guy it would be nice if it
had some simple rules that would tell me
exactly what the expectation is rather
than having to do it over and over again
right if I told you here's the gaussian
compute the expectation every time you
had to use that would be slightly
painful okay so hopefully this thing
being simple enough we've actually
selected a simple class that's simple
enough so that we can have rules whereas
as soon as I give you those parameters T
1 T 2 it I want it a to be an H you can
actually have some simple rules to
compute a mean and variance and other
things ok and so in particular I'm
interested in the mean and I'm gonna
have to actually say well you know this
mean has to be mapped into the whole
real line so I can actually talk about
modeling this function of the mean as X
transpose beta and we saw that for the
ketosis dataset or whatever other
datasets you actually can you can
actually do this using the log of the
reciprocal or for the actually we didn't
do it for the burn Allah will come to
this this is the most important one and
that's called a log it or logistic link
but before we go there this was actually
a very broad family right when I wrote
this thing on the bottom board it's gone
now but when I wrote it in the first
place the only thing that I wrote is I
wanted x times theta wouldn't be nice if
I have some distribution it was just x
time theta not some function of x times
some function of theta the function
seemed to be here so that they actually
make things a little so the functions
were here so that I can actually put a
lot of functions there but first of all
if I actually decide to Reaper ammeter
is my problem
I can always assume if I have one
dimensional I can always assume that ETA
one of theta becomes my new theta right
so this thing here for example I could
say well this is actually the parameter
of my burning let me call this guy theta
right I could do that then I could say
well here I have X that shows up here
and here since I'm talking about the
response I cannot really make any
transformations
here I'm gonna actually talk about a
specific family for which this guy is
not X square or X to the or square root
of x or log of X or anything I want I'm
just going to actually look at
distributions for which this is X this
exponential families are called
exponential canonical exponential family
so in the canonical exponential family
what I have is that I have my x time
theta I'm going to allow myself some
normalization factor Phi and we'll see
for example that it's very convenient
when I talk about the Gaussian right
because even if I know yeah even if I
know this guy which I actually pull into
my that's over here right right I know
Sigma squared but I don't want to change
my parameter to be mu over Sigma square
it's kind of painful so I just take mu
and I'm gonna keep this guy as being
this Phi over there and it's called the
dispersion parameter from a clear
analogy with the with the Gaussian right
that's the variance and that's measuring
dispersion okay so here what I want is
I'm gonna think throughout this class
some Phi may be known or not and
depending when it's not known this
actually might turn into some
exponential family or it might not
and the main reason is because this B of
theta over Phi is not necessarily a
function of theta over 5 right if I
actually have five unknown then Y theta
over Phi has to be this guy has to be my
new parameter and B might not be a
function of this new parameter okay so
you know we I'm just it may or may not
but this is not really a concern that
we're gonna have because throughout this
class we're gonna assume that Phi is
known ok Phi is gonna be known all the
time which means that this is always an
exponential family and it's just the
simplest one you could think of one
dimensional parameter one dimensional
response and I just have the the product
is just Y times or we used to call it X
now I've switched to Y but Y times theta
divided by Phi
okay should I write this or this is
clear to everyone what this says let me
write it somewhere so we actually keep
track of it for thee okay so this is we
have remember we had all the
distributions and then here we have the
exponential family and now we have the
canonical exponential family it's
actually much much smaller
well actually it's probably sort of a
good picture and what I have is that my
density or my PMF is just exponential Y
times theta minus B of theta divided by
Phi and I have plus C of oh yeah plus C
of Wi-Fi which means that this is really
if Phi is known H of Y is just
exponential C of Wi-Fi right agreed
actually this is the reason why it's not
necessarily a canonical family it might
not be that this depends only on Y it
could depend on Y and Phi in some
annoying way and I can may not be able
to break it okay but if Phi is known
this is just a function that depends on
Y agreed
those are the two same this is in
particular I think you need I hope you
can convince yourself that this is just
a sub case of everything we've seen
before all right
so for example the Gaussian when the
variance is known is indeed of this form
right so we still have it on the board
so here's my Y right so let me write
this as f theta Y so every X is replaced
with Y blah blah blah
this is this guy and now what I have is
that this is gonna be my Phi this is my
parameter theta so I'm definitely of the
form Y times theta divided by Phi and
then here I have a function B that
depends only on theta over Phi again
alright so B of theta is mu squared
divided by 2 okay then it's divided by C
Sigma Square and then I have this extra
stuff but I really don't care what it is
for now it's just something that depends
only on Y and known stuff ok so it's
just a function of white just like my H
I stuff everything in there the B though
this thing here this is actually what's
important because in a canonical family
if you think about it when you know Phi
sorry this is right this is just Y times
theta skilled by unknown constant the
sorry Y times theta scale by known
constant is the first term the second
term is B of theta scaled by some one
constant but B of theta is what's gonna
make the difference between Gaussian and
Bernoulli's and gammas and betas this is
all in this B of theta B F theta
contains everything that's idiosyncratic
to this particular distribution and so
this is gonna be important and we will
see that P of theta is going to capture
information about the mean about the
variance about likelihood about
everything
okay should I go through this
computation I mean it's the same you
just we've just done it right so maybe
it's probably better if you can redo it
on your own all right so the canonical
exponential family also has other
distributions right so there's the
Gaussian and there's the puesto and
there's the bernly but the other ones
may not be part of this right in
particular think about the gamma
distribution we had this log X was one
of the things that showed up I mean
there's I cannot get rid of this log X I
mean that's part of it except if a is
equal to one and I know it for sure
right so if a is equal to one then I'm
gonna have a minus one which is equal to
zero so I'm going to have a minus 1
times log X which is going to be just
zero so log X is going to vanish from
here but if a is equal to one then this
distribution is actually much nicer and
it actually does not even deserve the
name gamma what is it if a is equal to
one it's an exponential right gamma of 1
is equal to 1 X to the minus 1 is equal
to 1 B so I have exponential x over B
divided by B so 1 over B call it lambda
and this is just an exponential
distribution and so every time you're
gonna see something so all these guys
that don't make it to this table they
could be part of those guys but they're
just more they're just - they're just
have another name in this thing all
right so you could compute the value of
theta for different values right so
again you still have some continuous or
discrete ones this is my D of theta and
I said this is actually really what
captures my fear this B is actually
called cumulant generating function ok I
don't have time
I could write 5 slides to explain to you
but it would just only tell you why it's
called cumulant district generating
function it's also known as the log of
the moment generating function and why
it's called cumulant there the cumulant
generating function is because if I
start taking successive derivatives and
evaluating that at 0 I get the
successive cumulants of this
distribution which are some
transformation of the moments
the function B so this is just
normalization so this is just to tell
you I can compute this but I really
don't care and obviously I don't care
about stuff that's complicated this is
actually cute and this is what completes
everything and the rest is just like
some general description you don't need
me to tell you that the range of Y is 0
to infinity right and that's is
essentially telling me this is going to
give me some hints as to which link
function I should be using right because
the range of Y tells me what the range
of expectation of Y is gonna be all
right here it tells me that the range of
Y is between 0 and 1 ok so what I want
to show you is that this captures a
variety of different ranges that you can
have okay
so I'm gonna want to go into the
likelihood and the likelihood I'm
actually going to use to compute the
expectations but since I actually don't
have time to do this now let's just go
quickly through this and give you a
spoiler alert to make sure that you
always on Thursday and really really
want to think about coming here
immediately
alright so the thing I'm gonna want to
do as I said is it would be nice if at
least for this canonical family when I
get I give you B you would be able to
say oh here's a simple computation of B
that would actually give me the mean and
the variance the mean and the variance
are also known as moments B is called
cumulative cumulative function so it
sounds like moments being related to
cumulants I might have a path to finding
those right and it might involve taking
derivatives of B is we'll see the way
we're gonna prove this is by using this
thing that we've used several times so
this property we use when we were
computing remember the Fisher
information right we had two formulas
for the Fisher information one was the
expectation of the second derivative of
the log likelihood and one was negative
expectation of the square
uhsorry expectation of the square and
the other one was negative the
expectation of the second derivative
right the log likelihood is concave so
this number is negative this number is
positive and the way we did this is by
just permuting some drip
of an integral here and it was just we
use the fact that something that looked
like this right the log likelihood is
log of F theta and when I take the
derivative of this guy with respect to
theta then I have something that looks
like the derivative divided by F theta
and if I start taking the into the
integral against F theta of this thing
so the expectation of this thing those
things would cancel and then I had just
the integral of a derivative which I
would make a leap of faith and today
it's actually the derivative of the
integral but this was equal to one so
this derivative was actually equal to
zero and so that's how you got that the
expectation of the derivative of the log
likelihood is equal to zero and you do
it once again and you get this guy
there's just some nice things that
happen with the Taylor taking the
derivative of the log we've done that
we'll do that again but once you do this
you can actually apply it and and
missing a parenthesis over there so when
you write the log likelihood it's just
log of an exponential ha that's actually
pretty nice just like the least-squares
came naturally the leastwise criterion
came that early when we took the log
likelihood of the gaussians we're gonna
have the same thing that happens when I
take the log of the density the
exponential is gonna go away and then
I'm gonna use this formula but this
formula is going to actually give me any
quit an equation directly oh that's
where it was so that's the one that's
missing it there and so the expectation
minus this thing is going to be equal to
zero which tells me that the expectation
is just the derivative right so it's
still a function of theta
there's just the derivative of B and the
variance is just going to be the second
derivative of B but remember this was
some sort of a scaling right it's called
the dispersion parameter so the if I had
a Gaussian and the variance of the
Gaussian did not depend on the Sigma
square which I stuffed in this Phi that
would be certainly weird and it cannot
depend on the MU and so this will for
the guy
this is definitely going to be equal to
one and this is just going to be equal
to my variance okay so this is just by
taking the second derivative message is
that this function B captures by taking
one derivative the expectation by taking
two derivatives captures the variance
another thing that's actually cool and
we'll come back to this and I want to
think about is if this second derivative
is the variance what can I say about
this thing what do I know about the
variance yeah it's positive so we know
that this is positive so what does it
tell me positive
let's convex write a function it has
positive second derivative is convex so
we're gonna use that as well all right
so yeah I'll see you on Thursday I have
your homework